she's also known for roles in cult
classics like Cruel Intentions Hellboy
the sweetest thing in a 2018 Instagram
post Blair revealed that she was
diagnosed with multiple sclerosis since
then she has shared her journey and
become an advocate for people with
chronic illnesses and disabilities her
book is called mean baby I love this
title Memoir of growing up became a New
York Times bestseller when it was first
released last year now guys it will be
available in paperback tomorrow so if
you haven't read it now you get another
shot at it so Mulberry joins us now for
her first broadcast interview ahead of
the paperback release she's here with
her support dog Scout thank you Selma
thank you we are so I'm so excited to
have you here this morning because
your book number one journey is a word
for what you've been through but it's it
was you were I think 22 years old and
you had gone to the eye doctor about an
inflammation and when you were 22 that
doctor said you know I've never seen
what's happening right you know I was 22
I'd actually
um I'd gone away to college hadn't done
an eye exam but I had been ill this
whole time I mean they called me Dr
Blair my friends because I was doing my
thesis on candida all these things like
what do I have like fibromyalgia I don't
no diagnosis but I was always sick and
so
um when
oh my God my brain just did this no but
that's okay when you were 22. I've never
seen doctor I didn't even accepting
people that have MS and he looked at me
and he said you have Optical neuritis do
you have MS and instead of thinking well
we should look into this I just thought
no yes I didn't I knew about everything
I never ever assumed I had a
neurological illness and I had been to
many neurologists because I had
headaches and fevers but Selma that was
at 22. it was continued to have all
sorts of different symptoms over the
years
all the time I had balance issues I did
definitely have prefrontal damage like
impulse issues which I think also help
helps contribute to some of the
alcoholism but it always went in and out
I was very much a private Drinker a
binge Drinker at home off and on it was
not at work it was you know I was very
careful a careful drunk and so so a lot
of it you attributed to alcohol so then
I thought oh God I must have fallen when
I was drunk I was quite honest with my
friends like yeah I got a little drunk I
must have fallen on the bricks I'd have
cuts and I'd go to the eye doctor and
it's a you know you're losing your
peripheral vision and I was like oh I
just have amblyopia I but it was from
damage from Optical in the writing so
when you finally get the diagnosis at 40
something yeah what did you think when I
got the diagnosis assistant late 40
something it seems I was surprised but
then it was like oh of course and when
the doctor said the first night you've
had this at least 25 30 years
um at least I was
happy I needed it you know when someone
is told continuously that it's in your
head or you're depressed or oh no every
mother feels this way when they give
birth and I'm like no no I really can't
walk it is so painful like so I just
thought I'm a wimp I thought maybe I do
have real mental illness that can't
differentiate between at all between
emotional or physical pain and I took
that and and so I did not trust myself
and living with that is painful and
living with that is painful to not trust
yourself or trust your body and then be
having all these symptoms and people
saying you're you're stoned or you're
this or that when I'm like no no I've
never tried that at the time so it was
so disconcerting so it just seemed fine
on my own time I'll just I'll just drink
I check out and so to find that out and
think
oh there's a story I can put together it
was life-changing and so that is so
important to me yeah and in the book too
really why I wrote it then after the
stem cell transplant that bone marrow
that was quite harsh but but amazing I
am in remission um with the help of my
neurologist now but to write that book I
thought I hope someone can see that
maybe there's more or if they've done
shameful things or you know choices they
made go easy on yourself because you
need to come out of it it's not going to
help anyone to stay down and add to that
yeah yeah well congratulations on the
book I know there's an anecdote in the
book about how as a high school kid you
wanted to be a writer and you wanted
people to see you as a writer and then
you were on stage and they said no
you're an actor in my life it was my
mother said you're going to write a book
one day and I will edit it and this is
what we're you know and and so that's
what I did I wrote every day and I was
in love with my English class the one
class that saved me that I did well in
besides photography and when my English
teacher came to that play Murder in the
cathedral T.S Eliot which was hard
horrible tap dancing on the stage and um
he said you're not a writer you're an
actor you're going to go at you're going
to go be in soap operas or something you
know that Michigan and I was like oh
crud yeah that means I'm not a writer
what you talk about being candid in your
book about when people have gone through
things you talk about a rock bottom
moment for you you're on a plane with
your favorite son Arthur your beloved
Son Arthur's dad you had a rock bottom
moment that you said was personally
humiliating but oddly freeing what
happened to you on that plane on that
flight I had been
um in Cancun with my son's father
um and my son for the first time we're
all together as a family we had broken
up right after the birth and I didn't
know what a flare I was in I had been
feeling very ill and and I was sober and
I checked in the hotel and in this
presidential suite there was this Grand
Bar yes and in them as soon as I started
to unpack I just drank yeah and it was
that easy I had been sober for a few
years but not really working on it I was
too tired to care and I spent my whole
trip in that room
drinking and throwing up and drinking
and so by the time I got on the plane I
don't even remember you were gone and I
was already dehydrated and sick I was
not actually drinking on the plane I was
I came into it but you were past that
you just remember waiting on something
passenger though took a picture someone
took a picture and then said something
that I might or might not have said I'm
sure I was probably really out of sorts
and I did have assistance in oxygen and
nurses on the plane and when we did land
I was in the hospital and woke up there
and
I was like wow this is rock bottom and
and my son is not dead yes and no one's
dead and I did not hurt anyone you
better get this together now a new life
and I did there's a great picture in the
book of you jumping in the water I love
this picture your body the way your toes
are pointed and what happened this was
probably the last picture that was the
last picture that was kind of the end of
my youth I was a really active person
and I just wanted I was on my friend's
fancy boat in Miami and I said I got to
get this for the gram and uh got to get
what those kids are doing and I
knew I thought I had Parkinson's at this
point and I didn't know but when I
jumped in that water and knew I actually
couldn't move I couldn't
I was like oh I'm done but Selma you are
now here you said you're going to make
the cane cool you ought to cover of both
and you're doing that you're doing
you're on the cover of Vogue with the
cane and you said look I'm going to make
this bracelet I think to be on the look
at you Vogue now yes at age 50. I had
been on the cover of Vogues yes in my
youth but it was fashion it was you know
my relationship with a photographer but
to be on this cover and to also
represent one quarter of the population
of disabled people people wow that
thought there is no way a note Couture
that they're showing someone that is a
little person that is transgender in a
wheelchair in a gorgeous gown to have a
middle-aged woman showing her cane and
so middle age is that what you're
calling yourself isn't it well I I also
want to make myself sound older so
people could say you look great you
don't say that anymore you used to say
10 years ago they're like 50 and fine